Scream more. Rip your flesh out more.
May you suffer. May Allah increase you
in your suffering. May Allah increase
all of you guys in your suffering. You
IDF terrorists.
Dear brothers and sisters, as we watch
what is unfolding today in we have to
understand that opposition is counting
on us to lose attention, to become
fatigued and to move on with the new
cycle. And just as we can't allow them
to dictate our attention, we also can't
allow them to dictate the pace of our
solidarity. And part of that solidarity
is going to be there to rebuild Gaza
short-term, long term. I am proud to
give my support, my word of support to
trusted brothers and sisters in the
United Kingdom that have started a walk,
that have started an endowment to make
sure inshallah that we're there for the
long run. It's going to be long term and
we will not forget our cause and we will
not forget the cause of and we will not
forget our brothers and sisters in
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well in so
alhamdulillah a beautiful beautiful news
when I heard this I was over the moon
guys I'll be honest with you
alhamdulillah
you know why because when these things
happen brothers and sisters subhan allah
what's what happened in Gaza and what
they did in Gaza, the genocide, the
massacre. We sometimes sadly say we
don't have Allah and we think that
Allah's just going to let them get away.
That's going to be a cost to that. You
massacing innocent men and women and
children. There is going to be a cost.
And you see this what they did in Iraq
and Afghanistan to the American soldiers
who were committing Yes. And I committed
suicide. Okay. The same thing is
happening on a pandemic like a tsunami
and the statistics and studies on this
brother and sisters from mental health
organizations. Watch this video and
you've seen many of these videos. Yes.
These are individuals who are in the
parliament. Okay. These mass murdering
genocidal maniacs. Yes. All right. These
Zionist dirt bags. Let's watch the video
for ourselves in the most satisfying
thing you are going to watch in your
life.
Here is another one that's going to be
even more satisfying, guys.
Scream more. Rip your flesh out more.
May you suffer. May Allah increase you
in your suffering. May Allah increase
all of you guys in your sufferings. You
IDF terrorists. What you've done to
those innocent men, women, and children.
Yes, we know. We know your esquetology.
We know what you're doing in Gaza. It's
mass slaughter to the unseen world to
give you specific powers. Okay, we're
not stupid. We know exactly what you
guys are doing. Even in your
esquetology, what you guys believe, you
Zionist Dbacks, the more chaos you cause
on the earth, the faster your messiah,
the antichrist, the jal is going to
come. That is what your esquetology
teaches. So that's the reason you can
see these videos. Look at them
absolutely screaming. Yes. Okay. Going
mental, having mental breakdowns, okay?
Showing letters, okay, of their fellow
genocidal comrades. And let's see what
Al Jazzer said inshallah. As we say, no,
sorry, the Middle Eastern eye. Israel
faces mental health tsunami after two
years of war reports finds. Okay.
Depression, anxiety, PTSD, and addiction
saw as experts warn of long-term social
impacts without urgent government
action. Okay. Israel is facing a mental
health tsunami which with 2 million
people in need of support as addiction
rates saw and families and communities
fall apart according to
al whatever it is. May Allah increase
you guys in that
make them increase in that. May Allah
subhana wa tala make their mental health
increase more. May Allah deal with them
for what they have done for those
innocent people. In an extensive report
published on Friday, the news outlet
said mental health professionals have
raised the alarm over a sharp increase
in people requesting support since sethr
October 2023. Meanwhile, there is a
severe shortage of therapists and
support services with experts warn could
have catastrophic consequences. May
Allah increase the catastrophe on you
guys. Inshallah. Last week, a coalition
of eight major mental health
organizations is organizations issued an
urgent warning to the government
describing the country's situation as an
outbreak of mental illness unprecedented
in the depth and scope. The groups
called the crisis catastrophic and
demanded immediate government
intervention. What is your government
going to do? The divine punishment is
falling on your heads. Yes, look how
they are screaming in the parliament,
throwing papers around. May you scatter
like those papers. Yes. I would wish it
worse for you criminals, genocidal
criminals. What you done to those
innocent children and people in Gaza are
what? They have in Allah. You will never
shake them. We cannot be the dust
underneath their feet. And we ask Allah
to forgive us for what we haven't done
enough for them. For our brothers and
sisters and gods. Subhan Allah. Brothers
and sisters. Yes. The psychological
state and well-being of Israel society
is at a low point. And we have never
seen this before. Alhamdulillah.
The long period of conflict and trauma
has left many people struggling with
depression, anxiety, intrusive thoughts
and exhaustion. Family and communities
are being excessively affected. And the
groups warned that the crisis has been
not yet peaked. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Hope it gets worse. They
warn of deep prolonged collective trauma
and growing breakdown in the public
sense of safety and trust likely to
conflict future generations.
Alhamdulillah. The psychological state
and the well-being of Israeli societies
are at a low point we have never seen
before. The co the coalition said
shocking numbers.
Data reported by the yadif a whatever
it's called sh show a sharp increase in
mental health problems nationwide
diagnosed of this depression anxiety
2024 would double those record in 2023.
PTSD diagnosed rose by 70% each month
from October 2023 to the end of 2024
adding third 23,600
new patients nearly half of Israel's now
report symptoms of persistent grief
calls to mental health help lines have
increased sixfold with use of
psychiatric medication has doubled sleep
disorders rose by 10% during the war and
it goes on alhamdulillah and you look at
the people in Gaza they say
How is it the ones that have been
massacred have don't have this issue?
You don't see the Palestinian arrivaling
theirel alhamdulillah they are stronger
and closer to their lord while these
criminals these IDF criminals die in
your rage. Like Allah says do not ever
think Allah is unaware. Allah is the all
knowing. He knows exactly the atoms. He
knows what raindrop will fall where, at
what measure, at what speed, at what
distance, and and where it will
splatter. Do you think that Lord who cra
who controls quantum mechanics? Yes.
Controls everything is unaware of these
criminals. Allah says, do not ever think
your lord is unaware of what the
evildoers do. He only delays them for a
day. Their eyes are going to look in her
horror and they are getting that
punishment in this life and they're
going to get in the hereafter. I hope
you will satisfied as much as I was. May
Allah subhanaa increase them in the
punishment. May Allah deal with them.
Donate to uh walk forever brother and
sisters to our brother and says in
Palestine. And alhamdulillah Palestine
is going to be free. I'm to lie with her
cat.